Speaker 1: Our weekly COVID check in, we tend to
do this Tuesday or Wednesday each week. A very
welcome update is that cases and deaths globally
and in the United States continue declining. Let's
start with the U.S. cases. U.S. cases are now down
just more than 53 percent from their delta wave
peak. The delta wave peak was about hundred 3000
cases a day. Being down more than 50 percent is a
great sign, and we're coming down at roughly the
same rate as we've been seeing for a few weeks.
If this decline continues for more weeks,
we will be in nice shaped by Thanksgiving.
Second, no guarantee that will happen, by
the way. Second, deaths in the United States,
those tend to lag cases by three to four weeks.
Deaths continue coming down from their delta peak
of just shy of 2000 deaths a day. We're now down
about 33 percent. Now that's still a crazy amount
of death. Every day 3500 50 people in the U.S.
every day dying of COVID. That's roughly. 13 times
that of the flu on an annualized basis. That's
close to half a 911 a day. But going down and
not up at this time is welcome. Globally, we're
still seeing cases decline. Globally, cases are
now down about 40 percent from their Delta Peak,
the Delta Peak, the global Delta Peak. These are
bonkers numbers. We were seeing 660000 cases a
day. We're now seeing about 400000 cases a day,
a crazy number, but significantly lower. And then
globally, COVID deaths also declining. We did see
10000 daily deaths from COVID at the peak of
the Delta wave. That's down about 37 percent.
But that still means 64 hundred people every day
are dying from COVID. Now, how about vaccination
in the U.S.? We've really seen a sort
of leveling off of vaccination. We're at
roughly 850000 doses per day at one point. You
might remember and you see it on this chart.
We saw daily U.S. vaccinations go all the way down
to about half a million a day. That was mid-July.
Then then they came up to about a million a day
and then declined and then back up to a million
a day, and now about 850000 a day. Now that's
not great. These are not inspiring numbers.
And the other thing to consider is with
more and more people getting third doses.
You have to understand that this number of daily
doses corresponds to fewer newly vaccinated people
because not only before we had to
say OK, if there's a million doses
and about 10 percent of people don't go for their
second dose, every million doses probably means
600000 people getting their first dose.
Now, with people getting third doses,
I don't know what the numbers are, but you would
imagine for every million doses, it might only be,
you know, 400000 people getting their their first
dose. So that's not great. Around the world,
sadly, daily vaccinations also experiencing
a significant decline. At one point, we were
seeing 40 million daily vaccinations. I told
you last week we were seeing about 25 million.
We're now seeing about 20 million doses a day
globally. We've got seven point eight billion
people on the planet. That's not great. We do need
to get more doses to countries that have not yet
really gotten access and try to scale those
numbers up. I've talked about, you know,
78 million doses a day would be great. Where do I
get that? Well, seven point eight billion people
on the planet. If you can do 78 million doses a
day, you're giving a dose to one percent of the
global population a day. That would be a great
number. We're at less than a third of that right
now. Few other bits of news. The NHL has suspended
a vendor, Cain, for submitting a forged fake,
fraudulent Fugazi vaccination card. We'll be
discussing that on today's bonus show. The UK
has one of the highest COVID infection rates in
the world. Why? We will be talking about that
on today's bonus show, and yes, there is a Miami
private school which is making all sorts of bogus
claims about vaccines. And they are saying if
you get a vaccine, you've got to stay home for
30 days. That won't be on today's bonus show,
but on a bonus show, upcoming wild, wild stuff
going on down there in Miami. Make sure you're
following me on Twitter at De Packman. We're
going to take a quick break and be back. This is a
this is a meaty show today. Very, very meaty show.